[Music]
behind that puppy filter is a pregnant
Khloe Kardashian getting her workout on
you know Khloe's taking a little heat
for working out with baby on board and
you'll hear about that in just a minute
but as Kelty found out the Kardashian
hustle doesn't stop even if you are a
first-time mom I feel great that I feel
so good I think just it's just all like
weird what's happening I think it's just
like you're growing a human and you are
tired but it's such a beautiful thing
any advice from assists a lot too much
like I've gotten to the point I'm like
okay shut up and take your own advice
that's why people love Khloe she just
says exactly what she thinks and when
some haters criticized for pregnancy
workouts she bounced right back at him I
could not believe the backlash for
working out pregnant I know can we
discuss that it's bizarre to me and you
would think people would be happy that
I'm staying healthy and fit and my
doctor wants me to work out every day if
I could so I'm doing doctor's orders and
I feel good and they say it leads for a
better delivery and I feel great and I
would feel horrible if I was just
sitting around overeating all day like I
feel like my I don't have swollen feet I
don't have a lot of these things cuz I
am staying so active right now Khloe's
commitment to fitness is helping others
makeover their bodies and minds the
second season of her eseries revenge
body is back we're gonna give you your
life back for me I think it's important
to show people you can turn your life
around you can go through hell and high
water but you can still come out and
have a beautiful positive happy life
Jennifer Lopez sleeps only on her back
and she's pedals around her Sunday's
episode features 48 year old JLo secret
to a flawless neck sleep surrounded by
pillows if JLo could do something I can
do it right yeah like sharing the good I
know we I didn't even realize this
sleeping on your face thing thank you
wait old I had to learn to it
hell are these lines on the side of my
neck I'm too young for this what is this
and I was like are they aging aging is
up and down it's when there's like you
have lines in the side of your neck it's
from side sleeping